paul  sported by lillard  paul spinning around the jumper is  because big time plays  hard drives  dunks  [Applause]  right by  capela's head to get the proper shooting  stroke as chris paul gets rid of the  defender chris paul putting olynyk in  the blender defensive rebound his three  [Music]  bart steps right  fires score  david here's hard with the drive  over the oakitch  oh pulls back reload shoots  scores  22  oh what a pass by chris paul in the  meantime just doing his thing and that's  all again and this time  today there's an excellent defender  there's hardened pulling it back  and  [Applause]  [Applause]  steps back short jumpers good  broke his ankles and got the layup wow  oh he put the shots down to three  barton steps back fires that's the game  [Applause]  gets inside lays it in plus the fouls  had a big half as well played a ton of  minutes now another three pointer is up  oh chris paul what a big shot for